this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday January the
23rd the joint is brought to you by
manscape listen if you're still using
your ball trimmer on your face get your
[__] together manscape has just dropped
their brand new beard hedger Pro kit the
beard hedger is cordless trimmer of your
dreams and it gives you 20 haircut
lengths from Mr Clean to Grizzly Adams
to everywhere in between and it's
waterproof so you can shave in the
shower in the toilet I don't give a [__]
and since manscape wants you to have it
have all the tools for the job they're
throwing in a beard brush comb and
scissors to make you look like a million
bucks so do me a favor get 20 off in
free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com again that that's 20 off
from free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com manscape beer headset one
stroke one guard 20 lengths one dime one
phone call 20 Puerto Ricans you know
what I'm saying the joint is also
brought to you by stamps.com
2023 is here so you don't want to wait
any longer to set your year up for
Success whether you got a small business
or a large business or just you know
like writing letters get ahead of the
competition by using stamps.com
stance.com let you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office it's ready to go in
minutes how easy is stamps.com let me
tell you something if me and my wife
been using it for over 10 years
stamps.com you can use it to print
postage wherever you do business all you
need is a computer and a printer with
stamps.com you can schedule pickup
and compare carriers and rates with a
click of a button if you're running an
online store forget about it stamps.com
Works seamlessly with all major shopping
carts and marketplaces so do me a favor
set your business up for Success when
you get started with stamps.com today
not tomorrow today sign up with promo
code Joey the special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
and digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphones the
top of the page and enter code Joey it's
that simple let's get this party started
cocksucked it's going to be a beautiful
day to be alive
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here Monday the 20
[__] third of January it's a
beautiful day to be alive and it's going
to be a beautiful [__] week to be
alive I've been doing great sorry I've
been cutting it down to just one podcast
a week but that's all I can handle right
now I got a couple other things on my
plate you know I'm raising a family and
[__] put a book on audio it's been a
[__] nightmare so work with me we'll
get this party started back up uh
probably in March or something like that
but a lot of shit's been going on a lot
of stuff in the news and I'm going to
talk to you about one thing that's been
on the news and it's bothered me since
[__] day one and I tried to think
about this and uh
you know not everybody's an actor not
everybody's a comic and I'm aware of
that and when I sometimes I come on a
podcast or I go on some of these
podcasts and I try to make uh you know
distinctions like to explain to you guys
what I feel about acting or you know
whatever the [__] going on at the time
this uh whatever this [__] name is
Russ the rush shooting Alec Baldwin this
has been on everybody you know the
decision got put out last week and then
nobody really said anything about it
like I didn't see anything it's not like
I'm looking and then yesterday morning I
saw there was something on CBS Morning
uh whatever about it and what they're
saying and now the Screen Actors Guild
is backing them and [__] like that let's
take it to the beginning here so you
guys know you have
and I think I've gone over this already
you've got you have a couple different
categories when you're shooting a sag
movie okay when you shooting a union
movie you have different categories you
have scale which is what you work for
which is I don't know what it is now
it's 659 a day plus 10 maybe it's 679 it
doesn't matter for the story
and then you have a sag it's called
something else like uh
a lower budget and that's 456 a day at
least it used to be
and then you have what's called like uh
I don't know it's 250 a day then you got
a hundred a day and then you got fifty
dollars a day yes there's movies that
they pay you fifty dollars a day for and
they pay it there with a [__]
straight face okay so
you know when you get to Hollywood and
you join the Screen Actors Guild you
have to build a resume okay and
you uh you do what you can like for me
in my case I was talking to a guy uh I
checked in with him yesterday we've been
friends for 25 years
we met on both of us first short film
like it was his first short film and my
first short film and it was a mobster
movement it's called another Bobby
O'Hara story okay and that was like
sag no payment like there's no payment
they basically got no budget you know
you go Joey why would you do a free
movie well because you have to learn
your craft
you don't want to go on a big 650 a day
movie and [__] it up and then never work
again
so what you do is you start off small
now in my case guys let me tell you my
[__] history of shooting
I shot a college film when I was in
college not prison college but College
college at the University of Colorado
and it won some film festival or
something I didn't go you know it was a
student film and then I did an
industrial
uh corporate video in Seattle when I was
coming up
and then I moved to LA and the first
thing I booked was a John Fogerty video
and
yeah yeah did you see it like a
hurricane uh
did they even show me no you can't oh I
am in it because I remember like a split
second and then uh
I had no film experience or nothing and
then boom I got lucky and I booked
basketball and I had no idea what I was
doing guys I mean
no [__] idea right and then I went on
that movie and I got a little you know
I didn't do as well as I wanted to
nobody said nothing to me but I just
knew by their reaction that I didn't
know what I was doing and that's fine I
didn't I wasn't supposed to know what I
was doing in fact when I booked that
movie I was walking by the audition
I was walking by the audition and she
goes are you here for the audition and
you know me I'm like yeah if you're
asking me if I'm here that means I can
read for it like I'm ready for it she
didn't know who I was she made a mistake
and I made a mistake
you know when and then just booked it
off for [__] watching movies all
those years just I just took like a beat
whatever I didn't know what I was doing
guys and I got put in basketball I had
no idea when I got to that set guys I
didn't even know
when they would say hit the marks
I didn't even know hit the marks hit the
marks and stand in your on your line
they put lines and you stand on that I
didn't even know that they kept saying
sir can you please stand in Your Mark I
had no idea what they were talking about
so as soon as basketball was over I
[__] him was embarrassed as [__] and I
got into a like a low end acting class
and
you know they teach you basic [__] you
know beats and you do scenes and then I
took a co-reading workshop and I learned
from the teachers they're like listen
man
we know you do stand-up and stuff but
you want to get your feet wet you want
to do different films so I must have
done guys
no exaggeration let's put a decent
number on it 12 to 15 College films that
you'll never see
that nobody will ever see but it was I
did this one I got to tell you about it
was about valets that do robberies in
the valley
and we were at a
like I didn't even live in the valley
then when I shot this I knew nothing
about the valley and ended up years
later I ended up going to that
restaurant where my wife was called
michelli's was it michelli's no no
that's in Hollywood this was up in the
valley it doesn't really matter
we played valet guys that people would
come in and we'd steal their cars take
their keys go to the house and Rob them
while they were eating dinner
and I'll never forget that when I got
there was all Chinese crew I'm like what
the [__] is this everybody's Chinese I
didn't care they're probably a lot
better than me at shooting I don't know
and
when they screamed the movie I happen to
go to that one because it was like right
across the street from the comedy store
or something and all they shot were feet
obviously they didn't know what they
were doing either all you saw was legs
you saw me one time I had that's it
everything you saw was the legs running
to them back the cars so everybody's
learning it's a learning process guys
so you'll say to me Joey like you did
Spider-Man too I don't know you got to
do those shitty films to get to where
you're going
I did all those and then I just sat back
and I booked uh
I booked uh Mad TV that's Screen Actors
Guild but that's not a a movie and then
I booked and then I started booking
you know Analyze That and taxi and you
guys know the rest of the story but in
there I mean I can't come to my mind now
how many
you know the first movie I shot that was
in scale was 250 and it was very easy I
had to go to Venice I played a producer
and you know whatever they paid I think
I worked two days total of 500 bucks
whatever no big deal but that's the
first time and then I started when you
guys see those dogs that saved Christmas
and the dog the same Halloween and all
those Disney movies they're 100 a day
movies
I didn't mind doing them guys you know
me I got no ego but let me tell you what
happens
okay when you shoot a movie it's I'm a
writer right let's say I'm a writer and
I write a script and I write a script
about my family and I'm very connected
to it you know I'm very connected to the
script the script has a meaning to me
and I [__] talk to Pacino I'm just
throwing names here guys I don't want
you to you talk to pachina I talked to
pachino and I talked to all their agents
I talked to Crystal for walking
and we get them on board I got an 11
million dollar
Budget on this movie I went out and
raised 11 million dollars from some
hedge fund or whatever
and then what happens as we're going to
shoot the movie Something Happens the
ones hedge fudge guys goes well we
thought you were going to get uh Ray
Liotta
we didn't agree on [__] you know
Pacino we're pulling our money out and
now you're left with
five million dollars that categorizes
your movie in a different movie I'm not
sure what the SAG things are and I don't
I'm talking out of my ass here it comes
to its budget so if you don't have the
budget for a screen a scale movie then
it breaks down to 450 a day or 250 a day
and whatnot so when when you're broke
right
and you go to the supermarket right if
you got twenty dollars and that's what
you're going to eat for the week and you
go to the supermarket you're not gonna
get uh
Canada Dry Ginger Ale you're gonna get
[__] meluka ginger ale you know Tom
and Jerry's ginger ale you're not gonna
get Boar's Head you're gonna get [__]
Oscar Maya this cousin [__] salami
you know what I'm saying you're not
gonna get the good eye you're not going
to get Briars you're going to get
[__] funky cold ice cream there might
be a hair in there or a fingernail or a
[__] toenail
same thing happens with movies but
me being Blinded By the Light of my
project what I wrote seriously you're PR
you're Blinded by the Light
when they call you up and go hey you
know
this is our budget nine hundred thousand
dollars now you gotta now you have to
look at yours at your uh script and go
oh [__] I can't burn that car on fire
because that's going to cost eight
thousand you if I'm saying to you so all
these things get cut out of your movie
and then what's the next thing you do
you start cutting out you know what I
really want Joey Diaz for this role I
really want them for this role I need
somebody comedically for this role
can't afford Joey what the Screen Actors
Guild wants me to pay him I can't afford
Joey you reach out to Joey and make an
offer or
you get Joey light
you know what I'm saying like somebody
who's Joey light I don't know you know
what I'm saying like and that's what
happens
so you didn't get to shoot the project
do you want it because there's not
enough money
now again before we get into this [__] I
shot all those I earned my stripes guys
it's not like I walked on a set with a
scarf on no I earned my [__] Stripes
I did those student films where they
shot my feet where you have to shoot at
night you're pulling all-nighters on
these they're not going to pay you in
the [__] daytime because they can't
afford the businesses
so if I want to use holston's like The
Sopranos and I want to use in the
daytime they're going to give me a
number I got to take whatever they make
for the day I got to pay them twice so
if Ocean's make 3 000 a day I got to pay
them five grand for the [__] day
but if I use it at night
they just want a thousand dollars and
clean the place up
but all these things [__] the actor they
don't you know what I'm saying so while
you're getting your dream movie made my
script you're overlooking you know now
we can't eat steak on Friday no more
we're gonna eat cold cuts now you follow
I'm saying to you so I did all those
guys I did from 1998
to probably
2010 no 2013.
I must have done and you could check my
[__] uh IMDb I know a couple weeks
ago some guy did a reel of all my movies
and [__] like that I saw things I didn't
even [__] remember and he had a list
of movies that I did that he couldn't
get a hold of or you know I don't
remember these [__] things but my
point is that
after you do a bunch online like when I
did the dog save Halloween how to do my
own [__] stunts I'm pouring [__]
pounds
I'm falling down the stairs but myself
there's no stunt man then I gotta get a
stunt man to match you when I did The
Longest Yard they had a dude
to match my body type that you guys
never get to see he still runs around
Hollywood saying how much Joey Diaz body
double in The Longest Yard good guy but
you know when you do those movies you're
not gonna have a buddy double they can't
a [__] afford one
so you shoot in dismal conditions I
still remember going on Spider-Man 2
where they had lobster tails on Fridays
and you know when you walk in they had
three [__] gallons of pomegranate
juice at 25 a gallon and I would just
pick one up and take it to my [__]
room and then two and then for
Spider-Man like when you'd walk to the
set there'd be a guy that would [__]
walk you open the door for you and tell
you to don't step on the cables I don't
want to get electrocuted and you walk in
and he walks you to your destination
when you do 100 Day movie
nobody walks you you know when you do a
600 all day movie the girls come in or
what do you need a suit yeah they come
in they measure you and [__] when you do
100 Day movie they just call you and go
you have a suit at the house bring it in
we'll work with it so do you understand
what I'm trying to tell you here when
you work on a scale movie there's two
chicks that are like you know come on
let's do this put these pair of shoes on
when you're [__] on a 100 Day movie
you buy your [__] self you know
there's nobody there to help you nobody
to take the lint off your [__] jacket
because you sat on the chair and the
chick before you had a cat now that hair
is going to come out on the [__]
screen you know these you ever see a
movie and you see a mistake like a
[__] mistake like somebody shot a
stand-up special a couple years ago and
he forgot that he had a string
yeah you know this is what low budget is
that's what you're gonna get
now let's cover the other end of the
situation
the other spectrum of this [__]
situation is weapons on a set
guys
somebody told me once Joey how many
times do you get shot in movies you know
I got shot in movies like you wouldn't
[__] believe okay
and I'll tell you I never did a movie
before Brandon leaves that but I did a
ton of movies after 199 [__] nine
okay I don't know how many movies I've
been shot at or killed or whatever
I'ma tell you what the protocol is just
so you guys know at home you ready it's
this [__] easy
you get on the set everybody welcomes
you how you doing nice to meet you I'm
the first ad I'm wardrobe I'm this I'm
the cook nice to meet you okay we're
gonna go to your trailer relax for 10-15
minutes put your stuff down
get your head together we'll come in
we'll bring in your wardrobe
and then people coming to talk to you
this is your first day so now you get
like the Wardrobe chick comes in to
check your sizes or whatever or to bring
your clothes in you've already been to
wardrobe then a guy comes in and throws
paperwork at you you gotta do 22 Pages
paperwork right when you get there you
know everything they already have your
name address all that [__] then the
armorer comes in
and he introduces himself he tells you
what scene number you're in
what uh what they expecting like on this
scene you're going to be shooting him or
he's going to be shooting you hey they
just break it down don't worry about it
we'll go over it and block him
and they introduce themselves and they
talk to you once you get dressed and go
through the hoopla once you get to that
shoot scene they really put attention to
that shoot scene okay and when it's time
for them to hand the gun to you they
turn the gun around and if it's a
revolver they pop the revolve and they
show you the inside of it if it's a a
[__] uh you know an automatic they
pop and show you the bullet in the
chamber shotgun whatever the [__] you're
carrying okay you get to examine it
close it and then you get to do your
scene when that scene is over no no when
that take is over
you ready for this not when the scene is
over as soon as you shoot them and they
go action cut the guy comes over again
takes the weapon from you
examines it and before they take another
take he opens the weapon again shows it
to you and you do it again this is over
and over
and you're there like come on guy you're
going to show me the weapon every two
minutes but because of Brandon Lee like
I'll take a look at that I don't want to
shoot somebody and I don't want to be
shot by nobody this is just common
[__] sense Okay so
I've been on those sets and they show
you the [__] gun and they do the
whole [__] thing and and this is it
this is what it is now let me tell you
what went wrong in [__] New Mexico
let me tell you what went wrong now when
I go into this I don't want you to go
Joey but you you're not a big fan of
Alec Baldwin I'm a I'm not a big fan
Alec Baldwin but I'm a fan of movies and
I'm a fan of humanity so I'm gonna take
that out of the [__] equation here
you have a hundred dollar day moving you
got guns on that movie okay if you
listen to the story they wanted the
armorer and they couldn't get him so
they went with the daughter instead
because instead of having to pay her a
thousand dollars a day they probably
paid her 150 a day I don't know I'm not
you have to look at the documents I'm
just telling you what I know when I work
on those [__] movies the food quality
is bad the uh you know because you have
to cut costs not to mention they were
shooting during covet
now I don't know what it adds to a TV uh
a movie but I know the TV show
CBS NBC Fox
when you shoot an episodic it adds four
hundred thousand dollars to the budget
that covert testing and that's for TV
and they spend a lot of money and they
do it I'm not saying that's what it was
for that movie
but it had to be up there and it affects
the bottom line like what we talk about
so now if you were thinking of having a
car explosion you definitely have to cut
it out because you got to pay for covert
whatever so this movie was shot during
covert
four or five days before the shooting
people started quitting the set because
it was unsafe because they were like
Yahoo's down there they were like
[__] Cubans on the fourth they were
like Cubans on the fifth when they get
the check from the government
they were [__] doing bullet practice
what's that they were doing targeting
practice with bottles and they were
using real gun
they were using real bullets okay so now
they had bullets scattered on like a
barrel
and they had so right there alone that's
negligence but let me tell you something
when you work with a [__] armorer
that's like a [__] marine or he's an
ex-con there's no [__] talk to
practice
okay you follow him saying to you so
right there that's all negligence number
two now is when we get into the Baldwin
situation this is a guy with a huge
[__] ego now I've been on sex with
huge he goes
they do
they push the boundaries to let
everybody else know how strong and
important they are
do you follow him saying to you they
push the boundaries
to push the flex on you to let you know
what they could get away with and you're
never going to get away with that
because I'm Alec ball went off whoever
the [__] the ego over the weekends
foreign
I saw it on the many Saints in Newark I
saw it on every movie I worked on
there's always that one guy
that he's a little bit more special than
everybody so he's gonna and in this case
if you know anything about Alec Baldwin
it was Alec bone remember years ago when
he got thrown off the plane because he
wouldn't shut his phone off because he
was playing like a [__] Pocket game
or something you know this is the ego
we're [__] playing with him
so think about this guy on this set
and uh
just think about his attitude I could
just imagine he was walking around this
[__] set
you know and no sets what burns me up
about those holiday sets I worked on a
movie called boilermaker
a bunch of [__] [__] in the end
of the day
it was a 23 Day movie
and we had to shoot 23 days in a row
because you were shooting it was uh
it was a uh you know like a a cast where
everybody was going to be in the scene
it was an AAA meeting so everybody was
going to be in the scene so there was no
days off for anybody
so you had to work 23 days in a row
and I get there and the first day that
great but I look at the crab service
table that's a little light guys
should I be angry
in a in a general in a in a
in a regular day I shouldn't be angry
but let me tell you something guys I
just want to tell you what I pay out
okay when I shoot something I pay out 10
commission to my agent
and then I pay
four times a month I gotta pay sag
a fee I don't know what it is 140
right 140 maybe 150 a quarter and then
at the end of the year
they taxed me
on all the commissions all the residuals
I get and anything I shot I have to give
them back two percent
okay they bill me on that on the 31st of
December
so it cost me about 800 nine hundred
dollars to be a member of sag every year
I know I'm a [__] [__] I know
and that's for everybody with the
exception you know whether you're making
eighty thousand dollars a year or not
that's what you're [__] paying so now
let me ask you this I'm paying this type
of money
when I shoot a [__] movie
everything better be in [__] order
you know my first five movies I went in
there with my nose wide open and I did
whatever the [__] they told me to but
after you start getting hit I'm paying
for this guys I pay a lot of [__]
money to Screen Actors guilt
and they want me to make like thirty
thousand dollars a year
to gain insurance so on all this [__]
guys it's I want you to know I'm we're
not one I'm not whining here what I'm
[__] telling you is that
I pay a lot of money so when I pay a lot
of [__] money and I go on that set
and I look at a [__] crab service
table now what do I want from a craft
service table
potato chips
some [__] fruit
some sodas some cereal maybe some
granola
just to keep everybody happy some sugar
you know not for me but for everybody
else these [__] had like 10
bags of peanuts on a [__] table
I didn't say nothing
then they make this they made us work on
Sundays now when you pull somebody away
from their family on a Sunday
do me a favor
make them feel
like they're special
I'm a cup of [__] Starbucks
you know when they get there I have
[__] McDonald Egg McMuffins
shows me that you
you can't no I get there on a [__]
Sunday and there's nothing on that
[__] table
and it's going to be a 12-hour day and
we're not breaking the first six hours
for lunch you know if you want a snack
you go over there you get an Apple you
got a [__] Yoo-hoo they had nothing I
threw a [__] conniption I just went
off I was just getting off Coke it was
like my fifth day off powder I [__]
went off in there they had asked me to
go home and I said I'll be back tomorrow
they better be [__] food on that
table I was pissed
you know when you're getting off drugs
you craving [__] sugar and [__] yeah
I get there on a [__] Sunday there's
nothing and then like a year later I
shot a a thing called rafaelos
and these guys were paying me a hundred
dollars a day
to be honest with you guys they said
they would pay me cash that's the only
reason why I did it because it was a
nice shooting I know from there I could
get hundred dollars and go buy a bag of
coke and that's the only reason why I
[__] did it
it was a pizza play and they were all
over La rafaelos rafaelos is a weird
thing because
Rafael's was like the dumbest thing I
ever shot in my life was on and all day
the first night I got there I was pissed
off because there was nothing on that
[__] craft service table but they
would give me a hundred dollars cash so
if you want a bag of peanuts you could
buy it on your own you know what I'm
saying I'm one of those [__] I
get it they gave me that long I tore ass
out of there and went to my dealer's
house and bought a grandma blow whatever
the [__] I bought but when I got back
the second night it looked like the Taj
Mahal in there
they had everything
I mean everything sandwiches pizzas
[__] cookies
you know why because the after at the
time it was after the after people were
there
and he's like how you doing I started
talking to the guy and [__]
I said to him can I ask you a question
he was the spokesperson from after or
whatever the the rep and he came on the
set to make sure everything was good
he goes uh I go hey man
that's a lot of food tonight he goes
that's the way it's always supposed to
look I go last night didn't look like
that and he went right in his wall he
gave me a card he goes anytime you go to
a set
and it doesn't look like that you call
me immediately
call this office within minutes because
that's the way that set is supposed to
[__] look but on those hundred dollar
day movies
they cut them
after 10 of those I was like
I really got to think about these all
day movies I'm gonna hit you with an ad
real quick I'll be right the [__] back
four and a four NFL teams two conference
championships I need my glasses for this
[__] and only a few more shots to win
big on playoffs with DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the NFL this Saturday and
Sunday is gotten down to Super Bowl 57.
new customers can bet five dollars and
get 203 bets but I'll tell you what
you're not a new customer you could
still get on the action with the stepped
up same game parlays listen the more
[__] legs you add the more money you
win take your shot at even bigger NFL
payouts boost your winnings with each
leg you add up to 100 boost so do me a
favor download the DraftKings sports
book app today use promo code Joey new
customers sign up five dollars if your
team comes in gonna win
200 in free bets instantly only at
DraftKings sports book with code Joey
listen minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details we got a bunch of great games
Friday and Saturday you're either going
to have Cincinnati against Kansas City
or you're either going to have buffalo
against Kansas City on Saturday and
you're either going to have Philadelphia
against [__] Dallas or Philadelphia
against San Francisco it's going to be
great [__] this is my time of the
year so get ready download the
Sportsbook app use code Joey and let's
get ready to have some [__] fun this
Super Bowl and now back to the podcast
all right so now let's wrap this
[__] up so
I told you the explanations and why I
feel the way I do about these low budget
[__] movies
now let's take a sag came out and said
that uh a couple people spoke up
for Alec Bolden sag was one of them and
a bunch of people already saying why
would sag go up back him after he
shot some like low set I don't know what
the [__] story was but here's my
[__] thing should Alec Baldwin be
charged
abso [__] lutely and they got charged
with two counts of [__] involuntary
I don't know if it's homicide or
manslaughter involuntary manslaughter
that takes a charge of what six to ten
years I did time with a couple guys that
did involuntary manslaughter and they
both got like six years you know getting
drunk having a fight at a [__] party
knocking somebody out and the guy dies
in the hospital that type of [__]
a lot of people are saying he should not
be charged
I'd [__] charge him if I was the D.A
when you do that bottle practice that
target practice it's like when I kidnap
Ken Bella
there was a machine gun involved okay
and whether I used it or not whether I
pointed at him or not it didn't matter
it was a potential for violence
potential for violence thing number two
he is the producer
I'm sick and tired this is if I was his
family I would sue Alex I would sue the
movie and to be honest to you I would
shoot a screen act as guilt
I'm probably gonna get help for saying
this but I don't give a [__] because I'm
talking from the heart here I'm talking
from
I'm talking from right you know
you work all your life you [__] put
up with [__] you go to [__] acting
classes you go to all these seminars and
[__] and then you're gonna sell me out
as my union to shoot 50 a day movies
with these people who are [__]
scumbags
you know I mean you tell me who you
would [__] who's responsible for this
[__]
if I fall and break my leg on a [__]
set I'll shoot a whole [__] I'll
everybody goes to take him down
everybody gets taken down because they
weren't looking out for me they tell you
they're looking out for you but they're
really not all they're concerned is
shooting their [__] movie
that's it that's what they do they don't
give a [__] about you or how you feel or
all they're concerned is about their
[__] dream
they don't give a [__] what you're going
through if you're not hungry you know
like I said listen guys
I don't like working [__] Sundays
whether it's on a movie or doing stupid
[__] comedy waiting all day to talk
to 80 [__] strangers on a Sunday
night why would I want to shoot a movie
on a [__] Sunday you know what I'm
saying so if we shoot anything on Sunday
or Saturday take care of us
give us a little extra I don't want a
hundred dollars you know I shot a movie
Once I was low budget with [__] Dick
Van Dyke and his son
uh you know those Hallmark movies they
paid 450 a day
they gave you a great lunch
I think I shot two days on it but they
put a bottle of wine in your room they
put a sweatshirt in your room and they
gave you 100 gift certificate
some deli in the valley I forget the
name of it now the one across from
Jerry's Deli
that on another card I used that three
times to get lunches I love Dick Van
Dyke I love that Hallmark thing because
they made a little bit of a [__]
difference guys
you know that's that's kind of nice so
you didn't pay me my rate but guess what
you got me a nice bottle of wine you
gave me a nice little [__] sweatshirt
you wrote a nice handwritten [__]
note
and then he gave me a hundred dollar
gift certificate to some [__] stupid
Deli art arts arts Deli in Studio City
how good did I feel after that
these [__] they don't give a
[__] so on that movie there hey
think about this people were walking off
the set days before the shooting that it
was unsafe that was it
that means it's on the [__] producer
who's the [__] producer scumbag Alec
Baldwin is one of the [__] producers
yes he was one of the producers on the
movie see when you do 100 all day movie
they what's Alec Baldwin is worth what
50 million dollars and you're gonna make
hundred dollars a day no so what they
offer you is the producer
a producer credit so now you got a
residual on a producer credit
and you get a producer credit and you
get an acting credit so if the movie
hits you get a check for life from that
producer set that's the deal they make
those guys number two they shoot those
movies usually during the holidays
because that's when actors are home in
La like whenever I shot on a holiday
movie I shot in December
because I'm not gonna [__] commit to
a movie I'm getting hot all day when I
could be shooting something for 600
hours that might come up tomorrow I
don't [__] know what's coming up so
they do them in December if you get
calls for those they're always like
we're shooting after Thanksgiving
because people okay I'll do four days on
your movie what and they'll go away to
[__] Hawaii or whatever the [__]
movie stars do
so they make you a producer if the movie
hits you get a check you know how much
of those [__] movies hit
not never
what's the trick from uh the boxing
movie with Clint Eastwood
that she died in the ring or see they
crippled her she did a movie that was an
all-day movie and the movie blew up so
now when you do a movie that's what they
tell you these movies are great people
see them no they don't Hillary Swank
this is a tremendous film on called
it's with Ray Liotta and and uh
I think it's into the blue or something
like that it's Ray Liotta and [__]
Dutch's wife
Justin Timberlake's wife
and the guy that played the [__]
football player Fast Times in Ridgemont
High
the big black guy
Armando Castillo the guy from [__] I
forget what the name of the movie is
it's a Ray Liotta and whatever his wife
she plays a stripper Ray Liotta plays
her father who got out of jail and wants
to reconnect with his stripper daughter
he doesn't know she's a stripper and he
goes to the strip club and gets a lap
dance from her it's [__] creepy movie
but it's not a bad [__] movie
it's a low budget movie
nobody ever saw that movie if you see it
and you go how come I never heard of
this movie I tell you why it's a low
budget movie so it was somebody's dream
to make that movie they didn't get the
proper financing who the [__] knows how
they ended up getting Justin
Timberlake's wife and uh and [__] Ray
Liotta and the king of Scotland's
[__] to be in the movie I have no
idea it's a great script like I said and
it needed to be shot but one of my
friends was in the movie He plays the
hot dog man outside the bar Armando
Castillo girlfriend Gabriel all those
guys so I saw him and I go man you did
great in that movie how come I never
heard of that movie and he goes because
it was a low budget movie
and uh
they ran out of financing
for the marketing area of it so this is
why what I say to you guys
on one side I want to do this movie
because it's going to help me build my
resume it's going to make me a better
actor I'll be stronger but on the other
[__] side
you know if I'm gonna [__] do
something to wear me out now I did them
for a long time and I did them with no
ego after the longest yard I did them
people would say to me why are you doing
these
and I'd say when I win an Oscar then
I'll stop doing this I'm never gonna win
an oscar but I'll stop doing those when
I become a really good actor
I started realizing that those movies
were [__] wear out because if they
give you a hundred dollars a day I gotta
pay 10 bucks commission that leaves me
at 90. I got to pay taxes then I gotta
dry clean my suit so basically I made no
[__] money
so finally one day I was getting after
the pan after the
after the strike in 2008 2007
it took a while to get things going so
what happened was
you know people were coming up on all
day movies and I kept doing them doing
them doing them and one day I go you
know what man I'm gonna get hurt on one
of these things I did that what about
the shark the Jersey shark [__] thing
and [__] with the programs you know guys
listen and that's what those movies are
I don't know when you're shooting that I
always ask myself when you're shooting
it you should be saying who the [__]
gonna see this
like nobody's gonna see like they would
come up to me and go Joey the line is
the car and I was in the back of my head
like
nobody's gonna see this anyway
why are we shooting this [__] once I got
to that attitude I stopped doing them
and I kept I kept getting calls from
calls calls calls and finally when I go
[__] this [__] I'm not doing any more
holiday movies I didn't work for about
seven months I was starting to get
[__] nervous
and I got the call from [__] uh the
Stallone Kevin Hart movie and I said see
you have to close one door before you
open up a [__] another
and that's it that's why I don't do
those movies no more and during the
pandemic guess what I was getting when I
moved here
the first three months I was in [__]
hell Mike will tell you and I was
getting calls
I remember calling my agent going I want
to work but I want to work in Jersey if
you could find me something there like
George Clooney
is shooting a movie in Jersey I'll see
if we get you in the movie let me tell
you something guys
I got like 15 auditions and they were
all hundred dollar a day movies and they
were shooting like in North Carolina
they were shooting like in Florida
[__] uh they even asked me if I
wanted to go to the Dominican Republic
[Music]
shoot on an all-day movie and I was like
listen
during covet
like I said you're gonna have to [__]
uh
cut the budget because they're covered
financing all that [__] so
I was like you [__] another holiday
movies were grind before this [__]
one of these movies now
and do I want to be involved with one of
these piece of [__] [__] movies so
that's I told my agent don't send me but
they kept sending me these [__]
auditions for these are all their movies
and I'm like if this movie shoots in
Jersey I'll do it because it's no
[__] you know I don't have to go
anywhere you probably have to pay your
own plane ticket for those [__]
movies you know they're low budget so
I'm like I'm not gonna get involved man
again it's not because of an ego or
anything like that because at the end of
the day I'm 60. what the [__] is it
gonna do for me I'm gonna go down there
and get beat up I'm gonna go down there
get stuck on the [__] plane get beat
up end up getting shot by [__] Alec
Baldwin or whatever his [__] name is
nah I'm not doing this [__] and I'm
happy I didn't he decided he was gonna
go down there and be a big shot New
Mexico
and shoot this [__] movie and look
what happened when I heard that this
happened
I was upset about the girl's family you
know somebody lost their life a director
got shot
but I was very happy that this happened
because it had to happen it had a
[__] these people getting out of
[__] control was sag and that's why
they shoot these movies out of state so
sag's not around
you know what the chat like New Mexico
sag is down there sagg's got an office
down there because they do so much
[__] shooting now that but when they
shoot like an Oklahoma and all these
other places Montana waiting exact
people gonna go up there they just want
their [__] envelope
that's why you have more freedom like
when we shot The Longest Yard we were in
[__] Santa Fe New Mexico guys it was
a [__] party down there once we got
to Orange County and we shot the next 12
weeks up there the [__] suits were
all over the set every day you couldn't
smoke pot on there no more you know you
couldn't do dick anymore
but what really cracks me up about this
whole situation
was as soon as I heard that [__] he
was getting charged I knew there was one
[__] that was happy and that man
name is Donald Trump that [__] I
was like Donald because today he did it
I read a tweet or something not a tweet
because he's off Twitter the day he did
it I [__] read this thing from him go
and throw him in jail Trump was like at
home going throw him in jail he's
mentally Disturbed his impersonation of
me was [__] terrible and all this
[__] I agree with him I used to look at
that impersonation and go who the [__]
laughs at that
only Gentiles laugh at that [__] only
people oh my God it's so good it was
horrible and he kept doing it and doing
it and doing it and finally Trump got
his last [__] laugh because if you
don't think Trump had something to do
with that I was thinking about this all
week and this morning when it was on CBS
Morning News uh Sunday morning
[__] it I saw this thing I went on the
computer and they had to CNN interview
and then under it was like a joke thing
going that uh the conspiracy theory is
that the Republicans and Donald Trump
got the D.A the [__] uh press charges
on them or some [__] which I knew you
know we're living in a day of everything
as a conspiracy theory you know
everybody's involved in a [__]
conspiracy theory you know for 50 years
we denied UFOs now they're everywhere
have you noticed it lately they're
[__] everywhere UFOs everywhere well
I tell you [__] two years ago about
the UFOs in Jersey I got so much hate me
well when we go to the city on [__]
Saturday night I'll stop on Boulevard
East if you're on Boulevard East but you
give it four hours you'll see a [__]
you'll see something going through the
air you [__] lower the window you
hear that Martian music
but Boulevard East they see him
constantly over there people who live in
those buildings will tell you [__]
stories for years when I did that
podcast with Jimmy Florentine
so many [__] people reached out to me
just talking about UFOs in Jersey and if
you Google it where are the most
sightings for UFO it's not [__] New
Mexico or Ground Zero it's New York City
go ahead look it up look it up right now
you people at home where are the most
[__] UFOs scene right there an hour
from here they dip down into that Hudson
River like Sully they [__] dip down
and they do their little they spin
around
and they get the [__] out you think I'm
kidding you dog you look at that Hudson
County report Hudson County Park you go
deep into that if you go on YouTube
1975 martians land in the Hudson County
Park in North Bergen New Jersey
okay if you go deep into that [__]
thing and then Google the paperwork on
it trust me I was on the road one night
and I was smoking pot and I went into a
[__] hole with that [__] I was like
because Rogan and all those guys always
talking about UFOs and they're like the
authority on UFOs and nobody's ever said
well
[__] Jersey you know New York City
Jersey just when I remembered that they
landed in Hudson County Park and some
one of my friends called me last week
he's like I listened to one of the
podcasts you talking about that like
they everybody remembers but they just
won't talk about us being kids going up
there the park had the police tape
around on the corner they were [__]
digging the feds were digging and [__]
they had those you like those people who
go to bees like work with bees they had
those masks on I [__] never forget
that [__] dawg I was a kid I was a
[__] kid so now everybody's seeing
UFOs Pilots that's all they're saying
them so I guess I was a [__] idiot
when I did the podcast couple years ago
because I'm not a martian guy I'm a
conspiracy theory guy I'm not a [__]
uh you know UFO guy but I do remember
that like a [__] and it didn't
say it because I hate all that [__] I
hate Star Trek I can't stand all that
[__] so
yeah whatever the [__] it is I don't
know science fiction fiction it don't
matter all goes up my [__] dick hole
but it's a [__] new week guys I've
been doing great lately I really have
this new year has agreed with me a lot
uh
like I said I had a rough week last week
a little bit of a rough week but not not
enough you know I get pissed off I don't
know where I live it's boring [__] like
that but not enough to you know I'm
happy here uh I'm doing this
the best job that I can you know for
what I got right now
I'm excited about the show Saturday
night it's the last show it's officially
[__] sold out we got a great lineup
we got Mike Klein Lee Dean Del rizzi's
coming Tara is coming it's gonna be
[__] great you know there's no
tickets available and I feel bad but
we'll start it back up again in the fall
and uh you know that's how it goes man
I'm not doing this full-time anymore I'm
just gonna put a little tours together
no planes
no [__] planes I don't wanna this is
the plane situation this country is
getting worse I think I'll drive yeah
yeah that's what I want to do I'll do a
residency AC something you know
something when the time is right but
this has been uh I'll tell you what's
been my strong point this year so far
I've been journaling
[__] great lately
I don't know what it is for a while then
my journaling was off
that [__] sailed my journaling is on
fire now I'm sticking to it
I've had a lot of problems sleeping
lately so I started journaling at night
to dump you know just a dump before some
nights I get too tired and I [__]
don't do it and two o'clock in the
morning I wake up and I'm pissed about
somebody [__] taking a parking spot
from me in 1984 so I had to start
dumping at night and uh it's just been
great guys you know
I had a problem last week they [__]
finally [__] stitched up this bottom
half of my face you can't see it that's
why I didn't do nothing Wednesday they
stitched it like I forget how they call
it on the inside they [__] swole up
and then finally the cyst finally
[__] busted so we're on the right
track there and guys I can't uh this is
the best I can do right now I could do
one podcast a week
I was struggling for a long time I'm
starting to get out of my [__]
struggle you know and uh that's it 2020
[__] three is here
I'm officially uh
whatever a [__] less than a month
away from turning 60 and it's been on my
mind a lot lately it's been on my mind a
lot I'm not bummed about it I mean
listen when you turn 60 when you turn 50
you start getting bummed that's when you
start praying at night you never pray
like you stop yeah you start used to you
don't pray at all till you're like 50
then you're like oh [__] things are
getting serious now
so you never [__] pray to your 60.
but 60 is a
you're no longer a novice you know what
I'm saying now you're definitely in
debt's [__] way
but I've been working out hard guys uh
I've still been going on my two jiu
jitsu's a week
I'm really enjoying that I'm seeing
progress there I'm seeing progress on my
health I'm losing [__] weight and um
I've switched my diet around I'm only
eating the eggs three days a week I eat
Special K and a bowl of fruit now four
days a week
it's a different life and I don't miss
the other life I had this is just
perfect for what I'm doing I don't need
to go up and jump up and down I don't
need to [__] shoot somebody on a set
I I just live my life now I really don't
care if the phone rings if it rings I
really don't give a [__] so
I'm looking forward to 2023 guys it's
finally starting to pay off for me and
uh
that's all I could tell you I'm excited
about the [__] Super Bowl I'm excited
about my birthday
my wife asked me if I want to have a
party
nah I might have like a little get
together maybe cook something have some
people come over but what am I gonna do
throw myself my own 60 year old party hi
oh my God but he's a jolly good fellow
get the [__] out of here my wife's like
do you want to go to a restaurant maybe
get like a back room not really
I'm not into that [__] guys I just want
to go out into the night and just have a
great time with my daughter like I told
you man my best night of the week is
Saturday night
We Got The Honeymooners so last night I
went over two nights ago I went over to
pickle Dairy I got some Chinese cookies
I got some Diet cream sodas and that's
what we had during The Honeymooners I
mean you're never I'm never gonna do a
comedy show on a [__] Saturday ever
again like this one starts at eight but
we usually get back about 11 30. you got
another half hour to go so at least I
could watch one of one uh one Saturday
night I came in and the mushrooms kicked
in as I walked in and she came right
down that'll be watching Honeymooners
I'm like oh
that's going great too me being a dad
getting a second chance this is really
working out for me and uh I'm just happy
for the first time in a long time guys
you know something was Eating Gilbert
Grape and I lived in LA and
I'm done I shook that [__]
and now I'm on to green and
[__] pastors man so
we're here it's another [__] Monday
it's going to be a great week [__]
powder your balls and let these
[__] know you're not [__]
around this week do not forget uh my
boyfriend Stoner Club came over the
other day and he brought me some [__]
like just a gift weed
like apple fritters or something like
that that [__] has some kick
through it guys so if you're in Jersey
and you want some [__] nice weed
delivered to your house he's got great
[__] Edibles I love his Edibles he's
got great Vapors those true dose Edibles
they don't [__] around guys so I'm
telling you right now if you're bored
you're lonely and you want to get the
party started go to stonerclub.com look
at the [__] what they got on there
and guys it's gonna blow your [__]
away they deliver right to you it's
cheap it's convenient if you use Uncle
Joey you get 10 off for life and uh
they're doing it in New York now New
York is back open I think New Jersey
still has some um
Sashimi laughing gas sashimi if they
don't if they're out by now we'll get it
for them in the next couple weeks so uh
keep going to stoners club I'm really
happy that you guys are using it I'm a
happy [__] a smoking laughing
gas I'm getting emails from all over the
[__] country I saw be real [__] be
real cold and he's like Joey this [__]
is laughing gas is tremendous guys and
it's even better in New Jersey because
everything is 24 and tastes like [__]
dirt
somebody of mine gave me weed I couldn't
[__] believe he's like it's it's not
good guys it's not good so if you can
get your hands on some [__] pirated
laughing gas do the best you can
[__] and without further Ado
that's it it's a beautiful Monday
Morning podcast guys have a great week
stay black and don't forget about me
hopefully I'll see you Saturday night if
not I'll see you sometime in the [__]
uh spring I love you [__] have
a great week
and uh see you guys next Monday tip top
Magoo and now for a word my
[__] sponsors
all right thank you for listening today
but as usual the joint is brought to you
by DraftKings listen four NFL teams two
conference championships and only a few
shots to win big on the playoffs with
DraftKings Sportsbook and official
sports betting part of the NFL counting
down to Super Bowl 57 new customers can
bet just five dollars and get 203 bets
listen man
I'm digging I don't know it looks like
it's going to be Buffalo and
Kansas City I I don't know so [__] so
good but hey it's Saturday and Sunday
and if you're not a new customer you can
still get on the action with stepped up
same game parlays take your shot at even
bigger NFL payout and boost your
winnings with each leg you add up to a
hundred percent download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use promo code
Joey new customers can bet five dollars
on the conference championships and get
200 and free bets instantly only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Joey
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details the
joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen when it comes to
stamps.com I love them because it's easy
to use Easy to work with and you save
money stamps.com lets you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office it's ready to go in
minutes use stamps.com to print postage
wherever you do business all you need is
a computer that's it and if running you
and if you're running an online store
stamps.com Works seamlessly with all
major shopping carts and marketplaces so
set your business up for Success when
you get started with stamps.com today
sign up with promo code Joey for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial and a free postage and free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code Joey that's it and the
joint is also brought to you by my one
of personal favorites because you got to
keep your ball trimmed up guys and
that's manscape manscape has just
dropped their brand new beard edger
broken oh my [__] god is this
tremendous I left mine upstairs if not
I'd show it to you [__] to be an
engine is the cordless trimmer of your
dreams and gives you 20 haircut links
from Mr Clean to [__] Santa Claus to
everything in between and it's
waterproof with a light so you can shave
in the [__] shower with one eye
closed and since manscape wants you to
have all the tools to the job and
they're throwing in the beard brush comb
and scissors to make you look like
[__] Johnny baluk get 20 off and free
shipping with code Joey at manscape.com
again that's 20 off from free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com manscape
beard had your one stroke one guard 20
links I want to thank manscape I want to
thank stamps.com and I want to thank
the best DraftKings sports book thank
you guys for [__] supporting and I'll
see you guys next Monday morning Tip Top
[__] Magoo love you stay black
foreign